blasphemous is a flawless game and it's
one of the best stories i've seen in
recent years its story is mysterious but
not so mysterious where the story
doesn't start making any sense the lore
is there and it is packed with
information but besides all that the
game had some other specialties in store
for me the stories of video games are
often crafted to invoke something in the
player whether it's the feeling of power
by becoming a god-like figure having the
game force us to question our own morals
or even just getting us to learn
something new blasphemous never made me
feel powerful quite the opposite
actually and i wasn't questioning any of
my beliefs but i did learn a lot from
this game religion as a subject is not
something i'm very knowledgeable about
still i find religion itself extremely
fascinating which is why i enjoyed
playing dante's inferno so much despite
not knowing much of what was going on
and blasphemous was the same i not only
learned about its lore within the game
but also the many references and
connections to real-life religion and
how that shaped the game's world it's
not necessary to incorporate outside
content into a game like this but if you
do it can further heighten the
experience so today i want to talk about
blasphemous and its story and not only
explain to you what's going on but how
well crafted the story truly is so let's
get started before we continue though i
wanted to give a quick shout out to a
new project that has been recently
brought to my attention lost and cult is
a gaming journal that delves into
various topics about the industry as
well as other topics within games
themselves like stories mechanics and
much more currently there are three
magazines that you can buy physically or
digitally but the one i want to focus on
is their newest entry the softcover
version is great as it has some
wonderful art but the premium and deluxe
edition has some beautiful art from
elden ring this specific magazine will
have a lot of artwork about the souls
games in it and also a lot of pages
dedicated to from software's impact on
the industry as a whole seeing as we
recently just talked about the souls
games i figured i'd bring it to your
attention in case this is something you
were interested in i'll leave a link to
the website down below if you want to
see it for yourself but with that done
let's get back to the video so the intro
of blasphemous is actually extremely
confusing as it shows a woman pounding
her chest with a miniature statue and
then getting stabbed through the chest
shortly after a person picks up the
weapon but then is seen waking up in a
field of corpses usually i wait a bit to
explain what's going on but for
blasphemous that is not the case so
allow me to catch you up to speed right
away blasphemous takes place in the land
of custodia and its inhabitants are very
religious everything from the npcs to
the environment to the character design
all leads back to religion even our main
character is religious as he is the
recently awoken being known as the
penitent one blasphemous references some
bits of christianity in catholicism but
also focuses on some of the spanish
versions of them the reason i say
spanish is because of our main character
a penitent is defined as someone who
repents their sins and seeks forgiveness
from god this also relates to the word
penance which is an act or set of
actions that are done out of repentance
for the sins that a person committed the
penitent once penance was a vow of
silence which is an interesting way to
canonize a silent protagonist but there
are many forms of penance like with
cressanta who we'll discuss later in the
game who walks without sight the one
thing they have in common though is
their helmets they're similar to the
capriote a mask that originated in spain
and hispanic countries that was made to
draw attention away from themselves and
instead towards god so already we're
seeing the major connections between
this game and real world religion but
you can't really have a belief system
without something being the main head of
that belief well in custodia its
residents worship the miracle the
miracle is a supernatural entity but it
has no body it's only ever been seen
through the acts it's done for example
the miracle was the reason that woman in
the intro died that sounds quite awful
but the key distinction is that she
wanted this to happen she wished to be
punished the miracle just made it happen
furthermore a person known as deo
gracias will tell us about the first
miracle about how a young boy wished for
pain so that he may ease the guilt in
his heart the miracle then took the log
he was sitting on and had to grow roots
that attached the boy's arms and legs
contorting and twisting his body into an
odd pose this was known as the first
miracle but the boy is also known as the
father or the twisted one who is the
being in the background in the first
level and is the being on the sword and
statue despite what seems to be acts of
violence and torture the people of
custodia see this as holy and even
worship the sites in which the events
took place the miracle to me is so
fascinating it'll make more sense when
we talk about the endings but what i
find so incredible is that because the
miracle is so unfathomable to normal
humans the people of custodia have no
other choice than to see it as a god and
as we'll see there is a lot of pain and
suffering that has occurred at the hands
of the miracle which is why the
inhabitants of the land are constantly
praying hoping for a way to rid
themselves of their guilt they see these
acts of punishment as necessary as they
feel like they did something wrong and
thus deserve their pain as for the
penitent one he has a rather vague
backstory he was a part of the
brotherhood of silent sorrow they
however were massacred as evident by the
hundreds of bodies what this brotherhood
was and what it did to deserve this is
unknown but it is assumed to have been
excommunicated or cast out by the
current pope escobar during the game's
development a comic was released called
the kneeling which shows the penitent
one claiming the sword called the maya
culpa before getting killed by a woman
named cressanta croissant guards escobar
so it's clear that she's affiliated with
the church furthermore the first boss in
the game is the warden of the silent
sorrow who appears again later around
the outskirts of the church itself this
might imply that they serve escobar as
well or maybe are affiliated with the
miracle in some way it's clear though
that escobar dislikes the brotherhood
for some reason but i think the miracle
disagrees since the penitent one while
killed was revived by the miracle it's
not explicitly said that this is the
case but both cressanta and the other
woman in the comic named desombrato seem
to imply this is the case desomparado
says in reference to the miracle now it
has focused its thought on you and it
begins to know you proof of its first
gift was that your vow of silence is
forever irreversible but don't worry
even if i don't have your voice i have
your purpose for i am a guide and
scholar in the ways of the miracle
cresanta in the following pages will
then say if the miracle has really
pointed out to you you will arise again
upon the dead before the pain of the
statue of the twisted father who will
watch over you this implies that the
miracle has chosen the penitent one for
some reason this might connect to a
possible theory that escobar murdered
the brotherhood of silent sorrow because
of something they knew about the miracle
or possibly because they were against
the miracle in some way regardless
though all we know is that the goal of
the penitent one is to find the cradle
of affliction so that's our objective go
to the church and obtain this cradle of
affliction doing so will allow the
penitent one to complete his penance and
be forgiven for his sins once again this
is not given to us at all like how i
explained it as it sprinkled throughout
character dialogue and item descriptions
but now that a good portion of the
background has been revealed you can see
how something like this has the
potential to be a really fantastic story
it has tons of lore regarding its
setting and backstory as well as some of
the key players involved in the story
and what they represent within the game
world it's a magnificent story and we're
only just beginning and new beginnings
often mean a restart earlier we talked
about this game's connections to real
world religion and the intro continues
this as the penitent one after killing
the warden of the silent sorrow will cut
into its side and pour its blood into
his helmet this to me seems like a
baptism the penitent one like us is
beginning a new life and a new journey
and thus a baptism is needed to make it
official not only is this such an
interesting theory but this act also has
ties to christianity as the piercing of
the side references jesus being pierced
in the side at least according to john
19 34. it's explained in that bible
verse that jesus had blood and water
pouring out of his side when stabbed
with a spear and baptisms are usually
with water so the blood and water
combination could be a reference to this
furthermore the penitent one also has
the crown of thorns on his helmet the
same ones worn by jesus as i said in the
beginning of the video learning not just
the in-game lore but the real world
connections heightened my experience of
the game and while this may not be seen
as a valid argument for a critique i
wouldn't have done any of this had the
game not intrigued me it's why some
people get interested in specific
settings like the lands of egypt and
italy thanks to assassin's creed
blasphemous hooked me enough to not only
care about its actual story but also
what inspired them to create the story
in the first place after we leave the
building we can meet with deo gracias
who explains a bit of what i mentioned
before like the cradle of affliction but
he also tells us how to get there the
cradle is in the mother of mother's
church but to gain entry to the building
we need to carry out the three
humiliations to gain access to the
building deo gracias will also give us a
thorn the thorn's item description and
some of his dialogue imply that he is
the narrator for the miracle and he will
eventually give us a lot of much needed
information during our travels when he
gives us the thorn he says that if when
the time comes the thorn has sprouted
enough to cut us then we will be at the
mercy of the grievous miracle pain guilt
humiliation all of this relates to the
game's core idea and its endings our
character is on a pilgrimage to absolve
their penance a pilgrimage is often done
by people who want to travel to
religious sites and we're attempting to
go to a holy site that houses the cradle
of affliction but getting there
shouldn't be easy especially when one is
under penance we have to work for it in
a gameplay sense that's why we must
overcome the various difficult bosses
and enemies that block our path but in a
more narrative sense we need to take
this guilt that we are consumed by
recognize it and absolve it but if we're
gonna do that we should probably get
moving two things that will have
immediately caught your attention are
the gameplay and the art style the art
style is not only based around catholic
and medieval architecture but it's done
in a pixelated format i've never seen
anything like it before and i was blown
away every single time something new
came on my screen you'll meet the first
warden and then be drawn in by his
unique look to which you start wondering
what the other bosses might look like
and then you'll meet beings like
exposito and the melcuiades and are
constantly amazed that the quality of
these designs never faltered throughout
the entire run time honestly this game
has some of the best looking bosses i've
ever seen and i really think it's the
pixel art that sells this i doubt these
bosses would have looked terrible in a
more realistic engine like the modern
souls games but by going with a pixel
art design it makes you look at these
bosses a bit differently usually the
bosses are where most of the time goes
when it comes to visual design since
they are the finale but every character
in this game seems to have just as much
time put into them as these bosses it's
so well done i don't even have to cherry
pick them to reinforce my argument
joserno altus garcias the lady of the
six sorrows these women who used the
statue they were tied up on as a weapon
and whatever this is all of them are
stunning i mean this with no
exaggeration not a single boss enemy or
npc ever looked visually disappointing
or out of sync with the game's themes
and that's the reason why if there's one
thing a majority of these beings share
with one another it's that they're all
grotesque and disgusting yet no matter
how much i want to avert my eyes i can't
stop staring at them the art of
blasphemous is one of the best designs
i've ever seen and was a joy to look at
throughout the whole game as for the
gameplay i don't even know where to
begin it's just fantastic blasphemous
was the first metroidvania i've actually
played and this was such a wonderful way
to be welcomed into this genre i've said
before how i love when games tie combat
into narrative even if it's minor and
blasphemous does that by making the
combat difficult as this connects with
the difficult journey that the penitent
one must take to absolve themselves
blasphemous is a hard game there's no
getting around it when it comes to
bosses there are so many moving parts
that'll make you feel like you need
another set of eyes in order to
understand what's going on and even when
the game slows down the pace in between
the boss fights the levels can be
mind-numbingly painful to traverse i
must have been stuck in the graveyard of
the peaks for over an hour because this
entire climb is covered in at least 30
enemies all of whom can hit extremely
hard and there are traps and falling
platforms placed next to them so you
aren't allowed to focus on traversal or
combat separately you need to pay
attention to both the game at times is
also extremely stingy with its
checkpoints and due to the level design
there are only a few sections you might
be able to bypass just by walking
meaning most of the time a death will
require you to battle all the enemies
you just fought again it's torturous and
explicitly designed to torment you and
we haven't even gotten to the true
torment yet just like with the art
design the gameplay does not disappoint
the gameplay is fast paced fluid and
intense and the art design is this
unique blend that goes from barbaric
medieval cages and chains to glossy and
ornate walls and flooring blasphemous is
one of the most unique and enjoyable
games i've ever played and while the
regular levels and enemies do highlight
a lot of the game's qualities many
people will notice it in the bosses
which is where it truly shines three
bosses stand between us and the three
humiliations the ten padad the trace and
gutias and our lady of the charred
visage and the stories of these beings
are rather intriguing to get to any of
them though the player must visit all
bro tyrso is a part of a group called
the kisser of wounds that seek to help
the sick and dying we surprisingly get a
lot of information about tyrso and this
is by far one of the best additions made
to blasphemous the game has been
considered a souls-like by many and one
of the reasons why is because this game
uses item descriptions to tell its story
so souls players will feel rather
comfortable with this format and excuse
the pun i'm sorry blasphemous feels like
a miracle when it comes to item
descriptions as instead of the dark
souls series which could have at most a
sentence or two of lore blasphemous is
completely comfortable throwing out
paragraphs of information to us for
example tyrso wants us to find some
healing items for him because the
brotherhood is running out and each of
these healing items has a piece of the
puzzle that will make up the story of
all bro and the kisser of wounds the
first part of the story reads quote it
was not just hearsay anymore the illness
had reached all bro without warning the
outbreak and the punishment of the
miracle so often discussed came through
a young man who arrived to our small
congregation full of fear wondering what
his unforgivable sin had been to receive
such a condemnation and what could we do
a group of plain and profane healers
blind to the vague wills of the miracle
pray begging for its forgiveness what
would our sacrifice have to be for our
prayers to be heard at the mercy of the
miracle was that young man and at the
mercy of the miracle were the left the
rest of us with him it wasn't long
before more and more people came to us
affected by that terrible and unknown
suffering whole families the old the
young and even the newborn we brothers
of the congregation were unable to cope
and our care was not working though were
our ointments nor our constant prayers
we are lost submerged in the darkness of
uncertainty that was only three items
and it has not only provided us with so
much to read but also provided so much
background to the world itself the
miracle had created some sort of
sickness and the congregation was unable
to help them but the second half of the
story will tell us the rest quote on one
of the nights during which the young man
agonized admits terrible febrile tremors
with the wounds that plagued his body
spreading more and more i approached him
so distraught that i held him in my arms
and shedding tears i kissed him on the
forehead while i felt the ardor of his
forehead on my lips i noticed the young
man was opening his eyes and looking at
me his agony apparently gone all of a
sudden congregation members witnessing
the phenomenon watched in astonishment
except for one of our sisters who now
beside me and without fear of contagion
kissed one of the terrible sores that
the affliction had caused on the young
man and the wound began to close the
brothers fell to their knees amidst
tears and prayers ever since then our
pious kisses have saved hundreds from
the affliction of the miracle that
ravages these lands and from then our
congregation has been called that of the
kisser of wounds the second half of the
story seems to imply that the miracle
had possibly granted tyrso in the
congregation magical healing powers that
allowed them to combat the sickness the
miracle has spread this story is likely
inspired by saint francis of assisi
which is oddly enough the one piece of
christian knowledge i actually know
about saint francis in his early days
saw people he called lepers which were
people affected with leprosy as
nauseating but after his visions and
talks with god he began to appreciate
these beings and would help the sick by
feeding them and kissing their wounds
just like tyrso one thing to keep in
mind many of the conditions we see the
people or bosses in are most likely a
result of the miracle deo gracias tell
us that the miracle works in mysterious
ways and it's unable to be unraveled
meaning we'll never know its true
intentions which are why so many of the
people we talk to will say things along
the lines of what did i do to deserve
this or what has upset the grievous
miracle they're confused as to why
they're being punished and what their
sins were that led them to this
punishment which makes the ending of
this game such a revelation getting back
to all bro in case things go wrong
though the other group located here
called the order of the true shine gives
those who have passed on a proper burial
since this game is based in catholicism
it's safe to assume a version of heaven
or hell exists within the belief system
and while we don't really get to see a
form of that in the game we do get a
place called the dream we'll learn a bit
more about the dream later but there's
really not a whole lot of information
surrounding it like who's allowed to
enter or how the place even exists in
the first place but to me it seems like
some other worldly place that acts as a
sort of purgatory but it's a bit unclear
after all bro the player can go one of
three ways but each way leads to one of
the three bosses we talked about earlier
sadly not much is known about the levels
we walk through in-game but we are able
to gather some information from the
environment like the wasteland of buried
churches housing lots of people who are
strung up on posts in the same pose as
the twisted one implying that they are
most likely being executed or put to
death in the same manner or even how in
the snowy areas before the covenant
building at the higher tops of the map
there are frozen bodies everywhere and
from some item descriptions we can
discover that these were nuns who made
pilgrimages up here in order to attend
the covenant at the very top not many of
these areas are like albro that have
paragraphs worth of story but the small
details we learn can help contextualize
a lot of the events that occur in
custodia which is helpful
recontextualization is something that
will happen a lot during the playthrough
such as with the three bosses blocking
our path to the mother of mother's
church after the defeat of each boss we
can find a large room with a figure
inside and by prostrating ourselves in
front of it we can be taken into the
dream in each location is a head called
the golden visage and these heads were
likely the three beings behind the bars
we saw just moments ago and according to
some item descriptions were some of the
holiest of saints that were granted this
job by the miracle that job is to hold
on to the three holy wounds that when
put together will open the door to the
mother of mother's church the names of
these wounds are attrition contrition
and compunction and each of these items
has a design in the middle which is
possibly referencing the three bosses we
face as the contrition moon shows three
pointed hats similar to the same hats
worn by the trace and gutias and the
image of the compunction has two
different colors one of gold and one of
red just like the face of the charred
visage this means that these were
deliberately placed here and that these
wounds connect to the bosses attrition
is defined as a desire to not sin other
than the love of god contrition is
defined as someone not sinning because
of god's love which means that these two
words are opposites and compunction is
defined as a feeling of guilt or remorse
attrition is the holy wound guarded by
the 10 padad in english the boss's name
means have mercy or be merciful most
likely referencing the attrition part
according to some item descriptions it
seems that there is a living person
inside this horrific creature and that
they are as they say alive in a sleeping
body this being was most likely punished
by the miracle and turned into this
creature in fact this could be the same
creature from the introduction relating
this back to the holy wound of attrition
while we don't know what their sin is we
can assume that they were most likely
praying to the miracle for forgiveness
but only because they didn't want to be
punished and not because they
appreciated the love of the miracle
which is why this person was condemned
to this fate the holy wound of
contrition is guarded by the trace and
gutias which means three anguishes or
three sorrows these three women may
actually be manifestations of another
being found here called altus gracias to
even get them to spawn we need to place
down specific items which have lore
descriptions that tell us that there
were three sisters that all pray
together and likely wish not to be
wedded the miracle must have heard their
prayers and answer them by turning them
into the hideous beasts we see in front
of us since their holy wound is
contrition these three prayed to the
miracle out of love for it but were
seemingly tuned out or not believed by
the miracle and thus condemned to this
fate finally the holy wound of
compunction is guarded by our lady of
the charred visage despite its manly
face the charred visage is actually a
woman named oraya who was seen as
beautiful by the townsfolk she became so
well known and so beautiful that people
saw her as a living breathing image of
god she however felt guilty and didn't
want to be seen as divine so she burned
her face with hot boiling oil so that
she may never be seen as beautiful again
the miracle had witnessed this act and
decided to keep the flesh burning and
searing as if it had just happened this
however led area right back to where she
started as people started noticing that
her face was continuing to burn and ache
and once again saw it as an act of god
so now she is revered by many in the
land and a covenant has been built in
her name those same nuns we talked about
earlier that make the trek up here do so
with the intention of worshiping her and
the first act of worship is to pour
boiling oil on your face similar to how
oreya did so in her attempt to not be
seen as a godlike figure she ended up
being worshiped anyway her holy wound of
compunction is related to the original
guilt and sorrow she felt when she was
seen as a divine being which is why her
face is on the wound itself one thing
you'll have noticed is that a lot of the
story seems to boil down to the miracle
being the cause for all of this and
we're not even close to done yet sakura
was a girl that saw so many people put
to death that she started feeling sorry
for them and wished to take their pain
away and instead have it be brought to
her now she is in constant suffering and
pain but can never die from the wounds
nasimiento is another being we can find
in game and while we don't know much
about his past we can see another face
on his chest and apparently the face on
his chest ages forward but his face ages
backward at some point we can see this
being coming out of his chest and the
final interaction is the ancient being
now fully out of his chest with
nasimiento presumably dead or at the
very least unable to speak to us with
the limited knowledge given the player
is forced to draw conclusions why is the
miracle doing this and why is it causing
harm which is why the placing of these
next bosses felt intentional to me the
second half of the game seems set on
confusing the player as to what the
miracle is doing and what their true
intentions are in this second half we
can meet some of the bosses like
esposito mel cuiades and kirsay exposito
was a child that was blindfolded because
his mother was about to be burned at the
stake for being a witch but before dying
begged for someone to create a statue in
her image that the baby can feel safe
someone did and the miracle had
recognized this act and decided to make
it seemingly sentient so now it can
actually care for it as the mother would
have exposito is supposed to show the
player that it's not as harmful as it
seems and that there might be some
actual reasoning behind its axe this
could also connect to the previous lore
on the twisted one and the maya culpa
woman because remember they asked for
this they wanted the punishment we also
know that the twisted one never
complained so it's not like he had
second thoughts or felt regretful he was
content with his decision and the
outcome yeah some of the methods of the
miracle might be a little bit odd and
might be seen as harmful but who are we
to question the way of god many people
say that everything happens for a reason
or that god has a plan for all of us and
while we might not agree with the plan
we have to assume it has our best
interest at heart melcuites changes up
the story quite a bit as his story has
nothing to do with the miracle at all
using an item in the game that allows us
to hear the thoughts of some of the
corpses we can read quote i have
witnessed the exhumation of the
archbishop i've witnessed how they
cleansed his bones and wine to then
dress him in silk and gold i saw them
place the most beautiful jewels on his
face and kiss his forehead i watched as
they placed rings on his fingers and
kissed his hands they lifted him up
calling his name and swayed him to make
it look like as if he was walking again
mokuyares isn't even alive he's just a
corpse that is being paraded around by a
bunch of people this is one of the few
characters in the game not affected by
the miracle you could argue though that
the miracle is moving his arms and is
casting the magic but given how awkward
some of the movements are and how there
are hands placed behind his back it's
possible that they could be moving his
limbs too plus there doesn't seem to be
any lore suggesting that the miracle had
a hand in this he doesn't serve much to
the story but it's a nice change of pace
as it's not the miracles doing which was
quite surprising but then the game ends
up doubling back and talking about the
miracle again and its vicious acts as
quierse was someone who was said to be
burned at the stake because he was
deemed a heretic however he was falsely
accused he was never able to convince
the people that he wasn't a heretic and
thus to burn for it however the flames
that burned him were conjured up by the
miracle and now constantly burn and
resurrect him for life forcing him to
feel the burning searing pain every time
he's revived all of this caused such a
massive headache within me because now
we have the miracle doing kind acts and
people are now being pricks and digging
up old bodies but the miracle isn't
doing anything about it i was so
confused and the game was relentless in
its pursuit to purposely hide the
mystery of the miracle at this time of
the game i was convinced that escobar
and the church had something to do with
this the only reason i had this theory
was because no one was being spared by
this entity yet the only people that
seemingly weren't affected by it were
escobar and his people this could also
connect to the fact that he may have had
the door of the mother of mother's
church sealed unless someone obtained
the three humiliations but i was wrong
about this too as we know escobar was
seen as the pope or the head of the
church that worshipped the miracle but
at some point before the events of the
game he had disrespected the miracle and
was punished for it escobar on occasion
will appear before entering certain
areas and read off a line or two then
leave one of the lines he says is the
miracle has forsaken us and my ornate
throne turns its back on those who await
here due to him believing that the
miracle had forsaken him and the people
he rejected the miracle and was punished
for it similar to the twisted one
escobar started sprouting branches and
turned into a tree we can actually see
the tree for ourself when we first
opened up the door and when we're
outside the church and able to see it
from afar the holy wound of attrition
says that his holiness because of his
high penance must endure suffering in
his soul in three ways which would mean
that these wounds represent escobar's
suffering because escobar in the game is
referred to as his holiness so not only
are the people of custodia at the mercy
of the miracle but the leader of the
congregation the literal pope of the
church was being tormented by the
miracle as you can tell everyone is at
the mercy of this thing it doesn't
matter how powerful or insignificant
that person is as no one can surpass the
power of a god-like entity especially
one that can't be seen admittedly though
this is probably starting to become a
bit stale for some people the game keeps
using the miracle as the cause and this
keeps getting played out across the
whole game i've talked about this exact
problem in previous videos but where
blasphemous differs is that we're
actually seeing different outcomes
characters aren't just becoming demonic
beings like the ten pedad they're cursed
with undeath forced to be conjoined for
eternity or did something to themselves
that the miracle took notice of while
the cause of the events is the same the
effects are not and that's not only what
makes the miracle so interesting but
also what makes the story so intriguing
and mysterious as deo gracias has told
us many times the miracle works in
mysterious ways and as you continue
playing you become more and more eager
to learn about this miracle what it has
done to the people of custodia and what
the people themselves did to receive
this attention from the miracle at the
moment it seems like the miracle is just
punishing people for the sake of it but
that question of why is also in the back
of your head according to tyrso the
miracle created the sickness of all bro
which would make it seem like a
malevolent entity but it's also assumed
to have given tyrso the ability to kiss
those wounds away which would make it
benevolent that's why the miracle is so
fascinating you don't truly understand
what it wants all you can do is find the
remnants of his actions and decide from
there which also makes the miracle
equally as infuriating since it's
something we can't see if something
pisses us off in this game then we can
fight it but we can't fight the miracle
you can't fight what you can't see after
all however while we can't fight it we
can remove it partially many of the
beings we come across can be saved
because of us sakuro altis garcias the
lord of the salty shores and soledad can
all be helped and possibly go to the
other side and into the dream because of
us we can also help tyrso and the
brotherhood by giving them more ailments
so they can help the sick we can help
the man located in the archery by giving
him all the bones back so they're able
to rest in peace and there's even other
acts that we can perform that have
nothing to do with the miracle we could
help cleophas return to the order of the
true shrine and prevent him from killing
himself because we're giving him a new
purpose in life rindento is able to
travel to the holy site of his master
because of our help and joe cierno will
eventually be able to reunite with all
his brethren if we manage to save them
all we as the penitent one can help
custodia and save these people we're
able to take their guilt and sorrow for
ourselves so that they can have the will
to continue but is this guilt we've
accumulated enough can we truly say that
our penance is complete that we
understand the true meaning of guilt and
that because of understanding this we
should be absolved of our sins
well
let's see the final boss of the game is
none other than escobar one of those
lines that escobar says when he was
randomly appearing throughout the game
is that he was reincarnated by the
miracle that's how he's able to be here
while he should technically still be a
giant tree blocking the church he says
quite a lot of dialogue before the fight
but one part i want to point to is when
he says that he knows nothing about us
but only the miracle knows this further
solidifies the idea that the miracle
revived us for a reason and that reason
has to do with the cradle of affliction
escobar is a really easy fight but this
was meant to be as his actual form the
last son of the miracle is where the
real fight begins it's honestly a really
nice fight and a great way to cap off
the game it's not as complex as intense
as some other bosses but escobar comes
with his own set of quirks that make the
fight really engaging as mentioned
towards the start of the video none of
the bosses disappointed me visually or
mechanically and escobar was no
exception after defeating escobar we
meet with deo gracias one more time and
then we are told to climb the mountain
this mountain is covered in ash remember
when escobar was turned into a tree well
shortly after that happened the tree
burned for months once it finally
subsided all that was left was a
mountain of ash and at the top was his
throne anyone who witnessed this
immediately climbed the mountain in
hopes of reaching the top but all of
them succumbed to the mound and were
engulfed by the ash everyone who was
swallowed became a part of the miracle's
will we can assume that majority if not
all the enemies we face especially the
ones that are skeletal are people who
were consumed by the mountain and now
the penitent one joins its ranks we
didn't understand true guilt and we were
unable to climb the mountain deo gracias
puts us among a pile of other brethren
signifying that we're just one amongst
the many who have died i don't think
this means that other penitent ones have
existed or have tried to climb the
mountain i just think this means that
we're just like our other brothers
bracket the brotherhood and having our
journey end here would have been like if
we just died at the silent sorrow we
didn't accomplish anything and we didn't
learn anything so now we're just like
the hundreds of bodies that are part of
the congregation faceless nameless
beings who are unknown to history to
climb the mountain we're gonna need
guilt true guilt in blasphemous dying
will drop a guilt fragment from a
gameplay sense this forces us to start
with less magic as it slowly consumes
part of the bar however we can use an
item called an immaculate bead which
stops the gill from leaving our body as
it is now put into the bead after enough
deaths the bead will be completely
filled with guilt and according to its
updated item description it says that
confessors would carry beads like this
so that they could reap the guilds of
members of the church the confessor
statues for a fee will absolve us of our
guilt this is helpful if you can't reach
your last death point or you're just too
lazy but by destroying the statues we
can go inside a small pocket dimension
and fight the guilt confessors were
known to absolve people's guilt so it
makes sense that inside these portals is
that guilt there are seven of them and
each one grows that thorndeo gracias
gave us he told us that by the time we
reach the cradle the thorn is piercing
our skin and cutting into our fingers
then we would be at the mercy of the
miracle completing the dungeon will grow
the thorn and we can see in the updated
images that it's not only getting bigger
but more blood is being added to it it's
cutting deeper and deeper into our skin
so much so that by the end its original
color can't even be seen the name also
changes as well it starts as a thorn
then a sprout then a briar but the final
stage it becomes the custodia of sin
this is only accessible after defeating
all the statues and since the statues
are the only places in custodia to
absolve guilt we've essentially taken
all of custodia's guilt into our sword
this is enough to climb the mountain as
we are no longer slowed down by the
coarse ash and are slowly sucked inside
we are able to climb as fast as before
and push past our original barrier and
for the first time someone has made it
to the top of the mountain untainted by
its heavy burden capable of dragging one
down to its depths the penitent one then
sits on the throne and stabs themselves
with the maya culpa a sword that not
only carries the guilt of the woman the
guilt of the penitent one but the guilt
of custodia the final communion will
complete the penitent one's penance and
break off the ungodly will of the
miracle but the miracle always works in
mysterious ways it's never going to
truly disappear from custodia penance
and guilt come in all forms after all
furthermore the penitent one will not
have the same fate as many of his
colleagues he'll be stuck here and
unable to pass on to the dream because
we're the new father and the last son of
the miracle we are the new escrow after
defeating escobar deo gracias tells us
that we have freed his holiness from his
afflicted torment and now he can walk
onto the other side of the dream so now
the penitent one will have to wait for
someone to do the same to him for now
though custodial will see him as the
father and parade his wooded corpse
throughout the land as a sign of the
miracle in a miraculous twist though
crisanta arrives and pulls the sword out
of us possibly because she sees us as
unworthy and not a true son of the
miracle this could also mean that all
the guilt within the sword has gone free
and possibly has restarted the game's
events again back to the very beginning
despite its tragic ending it is seen as
the good ending of the game the pentaton
1 has completed their penance and is now
a holy figure of custodia what more
could you want
well more content actually and blasmus
decided to oblige and added a new dlc
later called the stir of dawn this dlc
has some content we've already seen as
nasimiento was added during this update
but if you want to experience all of it
and see the actual content you'll have
to go to new game plus the quest line of
hebreil and the amenities are only
accessible in true torment mode this
would be fine but blasphemous as a sort
of new game half plus because while all
the prayers relics hearts and beads we
have acquired stay the upgrades don't so
while you can keep all the beads you
acquired you can't put on all eight
anymore you're forced to go back to two
and need to find the knots again
furthermore and possibly the worst part
about this is that the health and magic
bars go back down to their original
state and any quicksilver and bile
flasks used are reverted meaning you
start with the lowest health and flasks
possible again but now the enemies do 20
more damage and have more health true
torment is an understatement it is
entirely possible to screw up the whole
playthrough if you don't plan
accordingly in the previous one the
relic that allows the player to negate
all damage for a few seconds was a
godsend for this playthrough and if i
didn't have it i may not have beaten
true torment mode the path of penance is
never meant to be easily beaten and by
making the content new game plus only
you can truly see why this is the case
despite my initial dislike of this i
came out of this experience much better
off i really enjoyed the requirement of
having a second playthrough and it also
helps with the story itself watching a
movie or playing a game twice can be
helpful for the story as you're coming
into the next playthrough with prior
knowledge so you can now focus on those
smaller details but not everyone wants
to play a game twice blasphemous however
locks the content behind the second
playthrough forcing the player to play
it twice which in turn allows more
people to understand the story one of
the lines that escobar says comes up
about 20 minutes into the game and it's
not until the last two minutes where you
finally see him in that form but playing
again you can recognize that escrowbus
was talking to us very early on in the
game to access this content we'll need a
new item called the petrified bell which
is given to us upon starting the next
playthrough this unlocks a new area and
a new npc called hibrill he by the way
of the miracle was named the messenger
of the sata we aren't given much info on
what the seita is sadly but we do know
that it seems to be some mysterious
force that is able to unearth some of
the secrets of the miracle it's able to
do this by playing a specific sound that
habriel is familiar with and it's
actually really beautiful
[Music]
not just this music but a lot of the
music in the game is really well done
especially in the above ground levels
where it seems like some loot is being
played and it's just really comforting
what this music unearths are coffins
that hold the amenacitas the golden
blades the bejeweled arrow the chiseled
steel and the molten thorn i'll be
honest this dlc has zero disappointing
bosses and i would argue that all of
them are at the top of my favorites list
as well just as they have similar names
they also have similar move sets but
they aren't completely copied and pasted
all of them provide a different level of
challenge and some players may find
specific bosses harder than others each
of them has this shield recharge that
gives them a shield that needs to be
destroyed first before you can attack
them again unless you interrupt them in
the middle of it there's also a mix of
moves that can offer punishes like the
chiseled steel sort of doppelganger type
move and the bejeweled arrows power
attacks but there's also a handful of
moves that you just have to deal with
like the molten thorn constantly
teleporting there is no way to punish
this you just have to deal with it and
hope you don't miss the decision to also
lock these bosses behind hibris
questline also means you have to fight
them on new game plus only which
obviously makes these bosses that much
harder but they felt designed for this
game mode and the move sets and damage
output reflect this i feel like the
fights wouldn't have been as memorable
if they were thrown into the main
content for most players these will be
the final few bosses that they have left
to do for the game so this makes the
fights more memorable and it also makes
the final stage that much easier the
final boss of the dlc is called loudest
the first of the amenities it's a
full-on four-phase fight she can also
not be stopped during her shield charge
at least to my knowledge because every
time she changes she goes into the next
phase while four phases might seem scary
you're actually more comfortable than
you might initially realize as each
phase is the same fight as the other
four bosses you're essentially fighting
the same four bosses but in one
continuous fight this is not only
incredible from a gameplay perspective
but from a narrative one as well during
the unearthing of the amenacetas hibrio
would give us some background on what
they were about when the miracle first
granted the wish of the boy who became
known as the twisted one it clearly
sparked a lot of discussion amongst the
people of custodia one such person
laurez became devoted to him by the
power of the miracle combined with her
immense passion for the twisted one she
was able to create four different bodies
formed with liquid gold which are the
four amenities we faced earlier laura's
and her four reflections would guard the
twisted one and parade him around
custodia but the miracle started growing
resentful of this because it had hoped
that laotis was showing her passion for
the miracle through the twisted one
since it had caused that event to occur
but laura's was specifically devoted to
the twisted one itself she cared about
the being the miracle created not the
miracle itself the miracle was annoyed
upon discovering this and thus sealed
them away in coffins including loudas
only capable of being unearthed when the
music of the sata was played across the
land this is a huge revelation for the
game because it shows that the miracle
has clear signs of sentience it has the
ability to feel resentment and anger
because of loudest which now makes
things even more confusing up until this
point a plausible theory could have been
that the miracle was just unhinged and
just doing things to do them without a
reason but this was deliberate it
intentionally did this but we're still
stuck on the why and that's been my
issue all game despite how much fun i
was having with this game and its dlc i
couldn't get this nagging feeling out of
my head that there was something more
going on what is the goal of a being who
has the capacity to unleash a sickness
upon people curse people with eternal
pain and suffering but also be able to
heal wounds with a kiss and provide a
being not only the means to revive
constantly but also be able to absolve
people of their sins and allow them to
die and pass on to the other side of the
dream i had one question that still
couldn't be answered if the main goal of
the miracle was for us to replace
escobar why cause the sickness in all
bro why condemn these people to terrible
fates why force us to go through all of
this it's a question that i had been
asking all game
and then i was given the answer wounds
of evantide is the final dlc of
blasphemous and unlike store of dawn
which has a plethora of gameplay content
wounds of evantide adds one thing
a new ending
an ending that is considered the canon
ending of blasphemous and was an answer
to my final question to start the dlc we
must meet petrova you'll meet her
naturally through the main game when she
ambushes you but you have to find her at
her grave she tells us to meet with her
brother esdras esdras has been following
us all game and if we meet with his
sister before fighting him instead of
killing him we force him to surrender
ezra then meets with us at the chapel of
the kneeling stone the same place where
the woman in the intro stabbed herself
esdras then gives us a key to take to a
man named diosdado who unlock a hidden
door within the library in here is the
secret item called the crimson heart of
mira
alright this isn't actually part of the
story but it was a nice reference r.i.p
mira the actual secret is this being
earlier in the video i said that there
were three guardian visages and three
holy wounds well there's actually four
this is the fourth guardian visage who
holds the holy wound of abnegation or at
least he did see the fourth visage was
different than his other brethren when
he was transformed into the state by the
miracle he was able to see something his
other brothers couldn't he could see the
real form of the miracle and where it
resides the miracle took notice of this
and turned on the fourth visage his
brothers also did as well which led him
to being deemed a traitor and a heretic
so even though he spoke the truth no one
was able to hear it to get him to speak
to us though we need to find his two
missing eyes that were taken and thrown
away one resides in the socket of
serapes a giant serpent that most likely
was just a snake that came in contact
with the eye and turned into what we see
now and the other lies with isadora the
singer of the dead she was just a young
woman who used to sing to those in her
village until one day she sang to the
long-lost beings of the audrey but not
only could they hear her they sung back
she then stayed there for the rest of
her life and now sings to the dead for
eternity i don't think there's any
specific reason why these beings have
these eyes in particular it seems that
the miracle just kind of wanted to throw
them away in the farthest darkest
corners of custodia so that no one could
find them after returning them to the
fourth visage he gives us the true heart
of our sword the heart that was supposed
to be embedded in our sword but it was
taken presumably by the miracle before
we could retrieve it the fourth visage
gives this to us and tells us to break
the chain of the most fervent soul in
custodia the one who has the most
devotion to the miracle and its
practices that of course being crissanta
crisanta was devoted to escobar and thus
would have turned its back on the
miracle during that time in history but
the miracle had its chains deep inside
cressanta and with this heart we can cut
those metaphorical chains off of her
cutting off the influence of the miracle
over her she was most likely manipulated
by the miracle because of her power as
she holds the final wound the holy wound
of abnegation abnegation is defined as a
rejection of something meaning we're
going to be rejecting the miracle
crisanta would have likely tried to stop
the miracle because of the wound but
couldn't because the restraints were
binding her she gives us the wound and
tells us to continue our pilgrimage and
by defeating escobar instead of being
swallowed by the ash or making it to the
throne we actually go even higher as the
throne moves up towards the sky and
eventually we awake inside the dream the
realm we have been hearing about all
game has been discovered but stopping us
from getting any farther is escobar as
his new duty is being the guardian of
the dream killing escobar is quite tough
but thankfully crisanta has found the
strength to join us with the two working
together they are easily able to defeat
escobar for good this time and can now
uncover the truth
penitent one who comes into our presence
bringing guilt to the most sacred of
places
to the most forbidden of temples this
being is known as the high wills and
everything we have talked about leads
back to them every time i've mentioned
something regarding the miracle it's
actually been the high wills these
beings are the cause of everything
happening in custodia all the fates of
the npcs and bosses the fate of the
twisted one the kneeling woman escobar
everything was all because of them the
high wills were a being who were spoken
into existence this was because of the
people of custodia unless i'm incorrect
given my ignorance on the subject god is
known as the creator within christianity
he created us this is the opposite if we
all collectively created a religion and
belief system we would need a figurehead
for that so we would all believe in some
godlike figure being the entity of our
belief system this was the same for the
people of custodia and due to their
immense belief in a being they called
the high wills it was actually able to
exist but only inside the dream dialogue
from the high will seems to imply that
this dream that they reside in is older
than they are furthermore inside the
stream is the path of ancient
processions which also seems to be older
than they are so they aren't the
creators of this realm they just live
here meaning that they are a more
powerful entities at play here
furthermore we also learn why they did
everything the reason is because they
live off of belief since a being was
born of a belief it can die of it the
more people that believe in the high
wills the more eternal they become and
the stronger the devotion the more
powerful they become and as they say are
able to reach higher than the sky itself
the high wills created all the suffering
in custodia so that the people could
pray to them more and thus give them
more life force to be able to grow
stronger and be immortal that's why the
high wills say that they used the
miracle to weave the threads of the
people's dreams into the path of the
ancient procession which according to
them is a domain where faith would
reunite in one single uninterrupted act
of adoration they are a parasite that
uses the devotion of the people of
custodia as a means to become immortal
and gain more power but here's where
things are going to get murky they seem
to imply that the miracle was created by
them and is thus a separate entity it's
my theory though that the miracle and
the high wills are two beings but the
question of whether or not they created
the miracle is still unknown regardless
of what actually happened though the
high will seem to be using the miracle's
power to cause all the problems in
custodia so it's not the miracles doing
rather the high wills using the miracle
i believe that the high wills revive the
penitent one with the power of the
miracle so that we could replace escobar
it seems clear that the high wills
wanted the penitent one to do the good
ending where we replace escobar because
it keeps their devotion going not the
true ending where we confront them
because once we do the penitent one and
cressanto destroy the high wills after
this happens the penitent one meets with
the twisted one who embraces him most
likely thanking him for what he did
shortly after though the sword will
crumble and the penitent one dies since
the high wills use the miracle to revive
us and now the high wills are dead its
creations are gone so the meia culpa and
the twisted one are officially gone and
the penitent one also stays dead since
he was survived by them in the first
place after the credits though we can
see a heart in the sky and a being
inside of it this is left ambiguous
because of the sequel set to release
next year but the question of what it is
can still be put in play here some
including myself believe that this is
the manifestation of the miracle we're
no longer just going to be seeing its
axe anymore but the real thing however
there is a lot of holes in this theory
it's possible that the actual miracle
revived the penitent one because it
wanted us to kill the high wheels so
that they could stop it from using its
power for themselves furthermore the
time frame of the high wills is spotty
at best it seems heavily implied that
once the twisted one turned into a tree
the people of custodia began worshiping
the miracle and that was according to
deo gracias the first miracle so they
couldn't have worshipped an entity they
didn't create or know existed but if the
high wills created the miracle how could
the people have spoken the high wills
into existence if they didn't believe in
something called the high wills this has
led to two theories one of which being
that the miracle was not made by the
high wills and actually existed before
the high wills were even created and the
other being that an older generation of
people worshipped the high wills but now
this new generation worships the miracle
this could explain why the words high
wills and miracle are spoken
interchangeably the lord of salty shore
says the words high wills and the
miracle interchangeably so it's clear
that it's two beings but the question of
what order and how they were created is
still a mystery to summarize this in a
brief a way as possible either the high
wills were born first and then the
miracle or the miracle came first and
then the high wills then there's also
the question of whether or not the
miracle was created upon the high wills
creation or later in the high will's
lifespan once again assuming the high
wills came first as if you couldn't tell
from the past four minutes it's a
[ __ ] mess but a sequel with the
proper wedding should be able to answer
this question and give us an answer to
what that being was at the end but that
however was the story of blasphemous a
place ruled by an ancient being that
used the people's devotion to continue
living and increase its power the high
wills then most likely revived the
penitent one with the goal of replacing
escobar and continuing their faith but
thanks to some divine intervention
whether it was the miracle working
separately against the high wheels or
the high wills had just simply not
anticipated this happening the pentaton
1 had reached its realm and destroyed it
removing its influence from custodia
presumably for good
what a fantastic piece of fiction
blasphemous has a fantastic story and
its ability to incorporate its own lore
with real imagery and references to
real-life religion was expertly crafted
as it feels like it's a part of the
world rather than just a cute easter egg
playing through this game was one of the
best decisions i've ever made and i urge
you to give this a try for yourself not
just for the story but for the gameplay
too it's a game i have zero complaints
about and has been one of the best
stories i've seen in recent years
thank you for watching
have you made it this far thank you
blasphemous was a really fun game and a
great introduction to the metroidvania
genre there is another metroidvania that
i do want to cover in the near future
which we've talked about before on the
channel and that is hollow knight i
don't know much about the game but the
little i do know interests me quite a
lot which is why i'm really excited to
play it it may take some time to make
that video though as hollow knight has a
lot of content to get through i'm hoping
for it to be the next video after this
but i may have to work on it in the
background while i do some other
projects in the meantime don't worry
though whether it'll be the next two
weeks from now or a couple months from
now hollow knight will be talked about
here on the channel if that sounds
interesting to you or if you liked the
video then of course like and subscribe
if you're new and as always thank you to
my returning viewers for coming back to
another video take care everyone
and goodbye in this realm of dust and
glimmering lights